A larger number of temporary immigrants over the past years in Quebec,
but elsewhere across the country is one that we having to deal with.
We took some concrete measures across the country
and here in Quebec on the measure of,
on the issue of, uh, uh,
international students that was, uh,
increasing far too fast
and putting at risk vulnerable international students.
Uh, we've taken, uh,
strong measures on asylum seekers,
whether it was closing down Roxham Road, uh,
or now reimposing a Mexican visa that has, uh,
brought down the numbers significantly.
We've made progress on that
and there's conversations to be had around temporary workers.
We know that there is a need by businesses across the country
to rely on international workers.
At the same time, we've seen those numbers increase in such a rapid way
that is putting pressure on housing,
is putting pressure on, uh,
healthcare systems and, and education systems.
Uh, we're all about, uh,
rolling up our sleeves and working with the provincial government, uh,
to solve some of these challenges, uh,
here in Quebec, but right across the country as well. Next question.